pendant très longtemps j'ai cru que
l'information
c'était ça c'était les journaux les
articles de journalistes
le travail de production de la presse
que c'était des infos et en fait au fil
du temps je me suis rendu compte que
l'information
c'était beaucoup plus que cela que le
savez un rapport avec la vie c'est ce
que je vais essayer de vous montrer
aujourd'hui
mais avant en préparant ce teddy j'ai
rencontré claudie haigneré que vous
allez entendre pour le plaisir d'écouter
tout à l'heure il ya une très vieille
histoire
kim est remonté à l'esprit hausse est
très vieux j'étais gamin j'étais lycéen
et j'avais trouvé un job d'été je
vendais france soir pour la plupart
d'entre vous françois ça veut rien dire
mais c'est un quotidien important et je
le vendais dans la rue aux terrasses de
bistrots aux terrasses de café et je
criais les titres j'étais crieur de
titres de journaux et je me souviens
parfaitement de ce matin de juillet 1969
dans la nuit des hommes étaient allés
sur la lune et le matin j'arborais et
fièrement la une du quotidien
je pense que vous allez avoir ici la une
du quotidien
je crois que c'est la première une en
couleur de l'histoire de la presse et je
criais jemeppe ou money on a marché sur
la lune on a marché sur la lune et c'est
bête mais j'étais fier que c'était moi
qui étais allé sur la lune
j'avais l'impression de transmettre à
tous et passant tous ces regards ébahis
ce joyeux ou quelquefois dubitatif une
information importante et je me suis
rendu compte et ça me rester gravé
l'information c'est précieux
alors le virus de l'information m'a
jamais réellement quitté
je les ai pratiqués dans les médias la
presse à la radio à la télévision je les
enseignes ici à la sorbonne en assurance
et presse je les décortiquer dans un
institut info mettrie je le pratique
aujourd'hui dans un super magazine en
ligne sur l'innovation et les temps qui
changent qui s'appelle pop magazine et
qui a été créée par fable et marion qui
dans cette salle mais il y a quelques
années quand on a vu l'irruption du
numérique partout dans nos vies dans nos
bureaux
je me suis dit l'information et une
nature très particulière et j'ai voulu
en savoir plus j'ai voulu aller plus
loin je me suis donc enfermés et j'ai
écrit un bouquin ce bouquin ces homo
sapiens 2.0 c'est une histoire naturelle
de l'information et je suis parti à la
poursuite de cette information je suis
remonté dans le temps et en fait je vais
remonter assez loin dans le temps
puisque je suis allé jusque au début
c'est à dire il y a trois milliards et
demi d'années alors il ya trois
milliards et demi d'années la terre
existait déjà depuis à peu près 500
millions d'années mais il n'y avait pas
de vie et puis un jour dans un coin
reculé de la planète dans un paysage
peut-être comme celui que je vous montre
ici paysage hostiles à nos yeux
contemporain une sorte de miracle s'est
produit
la combinaison de différents facteurs
chimiques et environnementaux ont fait
apparaître un organisme vivant une
créature la voix si j'ai son portrait
c'est une cyanobactérie c'est un
organisme primitif hyper rudimentaire
mais qui dès le début a voulu conquérir
le monde
il a voulu échanger de l'information
d'abord avec son environnement par son
métabolisme mais aussi avec ses
congénères et on trouve on retrouve les
traces de cette intense activité
on les retrouve dans ces amas fossiles
de cyanobactéries alors ce sont des des
10 qui font de mètres de diamètre
environ vous le voyez avec des
on est cécillon démontre une intense
activité d'organisation stratégique de
conquête du territoire de telle sorte
qu'on pense que ces petites bestioles
hyper primitive avait dès le début mis
en place une stratégie d'organisation
connectés de leurs informations et avait
peut-être inventé déjà l'intelligence
collective
alors on à l'entente longtemps cru que
la vie c'était de la matière et de
l'énergie
on sait aujourd'hui que la vie c'est de
la matière de l'énergie et de
l'information et l'information
c'est d'abord et essentiellement du code
vous le savez sans doute le code qui
vous vient à l'esprit c'est le code
biologique c'est le code qui est au
coeur de nos cellules
c'est l'adn c'est le gène c'est tout
c'est système de codification qui vont
faire le propre de la vie c'est à dire
qu'ils vont donner à la vie la
possibilité de se répliquer c'est ce que
disent les biologique pas de se
dupliquer de se copier à l'identique
mais de se répliquer avec des toutes
petites distinction des toutes petites
différences et ses petites différences
qui font la diversité de la vie autour
de nous vous le savez sans doute nous
partageons avec notre cousin chimpanzé
98% notre patrimoine génétique il ya 2 %
de différence et ça fait tout alors ça
c'est la codification de l'information
dans le vivant mais vous avez aussi la
codification de l'information que vous
connaissez dans le l'ordre des sociétés
et des cultures
c'est à dire que le langage l'écriture
je vais essayer de faire passer ces
diapos voilà le langage l'écriture sont
des codifications de la formation au
code des mots on cote des idées aux
codes des sons et
ce qui permet de les transporter de les
conserver et de les transporter dans le
monde alors il y a une dent ce fils de
l'information il y à une invention très
importantes capitales qui est assez
récente qui date des années 30
c'est celle de claude cheilan qui a
imaginé de coder avec des uns et des
zéros l'information de telle sorte
qu'elles puissent être répliqué à
l'identique
exactement comme dans les organismes
biologiques et cette invention a tout
changé
parce que en créant l'information on
crée aujourd'hui une information qui va
partout qui d'un clic de souris à la
vitesse de la lumière va traverser la
planète et se transformer par tous alors
cette information que j'appelle moi
hyper informations elle a tout changé
elle a changé notre rapport à autant
elle a changé notre rapport à l'espace
nous ne vivons plus aujourd'hui au
rythme circadien des espèces des saisons
le des du battement de coeur nous vivons
beaucoup plus autant d horloge à quartz
quasiment en temps réel
choisir la technique que voilà
alors il ya une caractéristique de
l'humain qui est un bien ou un mal
on verra ce qui est jamais content il
veut toujours aller plus loin et après
avoir bien numériser le vivant le réel
après avoir numérisé l'information qu'au
départ l'écriture le langage il a voulu
aller plus loin et numérisé maintenant
le vivant c'est à dire numérisés
l'organisation même du vivant
alors ça c'est quelque chose de très
important et on a passé une information
il n'y a pas très longtemps dans dans up
si l'information qui date du 1er avril
et c'est pas du tout un poisson d'avril
il ya des chercheurs du hem haïti qui
sont parvenus à créer un langage de
programmation capable de programmer des
fonctions dans des organismes vivants
dans des cellules vivantes
exactement comme on peut programmer des
circuits électroniques dans du silicium
on peut maintenant programmée avec des
lignes de codes assez simple presque en
open source
on va programmer des fonctions dans des
organismes vivants dans des cellules
vivantes alors ça c'est vraiment une
révolution parce que saleh sont rouverts
lab la porte à plein de choses
plein de modification et de manipulation
de la cellule vivante mais je vois qu'il
ya une information encore plus
importante une sorte de révolution qui
est dû à ces deux jeunes femmes en
apparence forte aimable emmanuel
charpentier et jennifer d'oudhna blanc
elles l ont inventé un outil absolument
diabolique qui leur vaudra peut-être le
le prix nobel et c'est tout si c'est un
outil au nom imprononçable c'est le
christ père le christ peur qu est-ce que
c'est ce sont des ciseaux biologique
c'est à des ciseaux moléculaires qui
sont capables d'aller au coeur de l'adn
d'aller chercher un morceau jane de
l'enlever de le copier de le remplacer
exactement comme vous le faites sur
votre traitement de texte quand vous
avez une faute d'orthographe ou une
coquille
vous allez cherchez vous la coupe et
veut la remplacer eh bien avec chris
perd on est capable aujourd'hui de
couper remplacer des gènes et
de les transformer aussi simplement que
bien bonjour
cette innovation a été lancée il ya deux
trois ans aujourd'hui appelée de plus de
3000 laboratoires dans le monde qui
créent des applications à partir de cet
outil phénoménal alors c'est sûr que cet
outil va nous permettre de manipuler le
vivent peut-être de guérir une multitude
de maladies mais aussi certainement
d'ouvrir la porte à des formes
d'eugénisme
peut-être qu'on pourra dire que nos
prochains enfants on va aller choisir
sur un catalogue qui sont grands ils
sont petits ils seront intelligents ils
auront les yeux bleus c'est ce qui nous
offre les possibilités de ce type de
technologie et là on pourra dire
vraiment bienvenue à gattaca quand on se
filme les les clones existe alors cette
effervescence cette époustouflante
énorme développement des technologies
notamment des biotechnologies nous rend
proprement surnaturel devenant des
sortes de dieu puisque nous pouvons
jouer sur le vivant mais aussi des
démons et je crois que ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que quand des gens
comme google 10 ou voulons tuer la mort
c'est qu'en fait ils sont entrés dans
cette logique ou à partir du moment où
on peut travailler sur le vivant à
partir du moment où on peut le corriger
on peut augmenter l'homme et on peut
peut-être atteindre peut-être pas
l'immortalité mais presque
c'est ce qui lui permet de dire que nous
avons vaincu la mort alors est ce
vraiment cela dont il s'agit est ce que
c'est vraiment ce qui sera possible
d'imaginer dans un proche futur
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on est de plus
en plus capables par ces manipulations à
faire converger le vivant avec les
technologies et que on arrive
progressivement à ce que certains
appellent le principe de singularité
c'est à dire ce moment craint par
certains est très attendu par d'autres
où l'homme va remplacer la machine
ou vous souvenez sans doute il n'ya pas
très longtemps de ce champion du monde 2
go qui a eu la joie d'être battu par un
tas de ferraille en fait une machine un
robot qui l'a battu platement alors dans
cette montée de l'informer de
l'évolution technologique autour du
vivant autour de la manipulation de
l'information
il ya des voix qui nous disent attention
là on est arrivé à des limites
on est arrivé à des limites
physiologiques on va pas pouvoir aller
beaucoup plus loin
alors dans ces voies dans ce concert de
voix il a une que j'ai est intéressante
c'est un garçon que j'ai rencontré a pas
très longtemps que j'interrogeais pour
un magazine d'ailleurs c'est
jean-françois tout ça il est médecin il
est professeur de physiologie
il est spécialiste du sport il dirige un
gros laboratoire à l'insep et lui qu'est
ce qu'il a fait il est allé regarder
puisqu'il les médecins du sport il va le
garder dans les records sportifs
donc il est allé regarder sur un siècle
l'évolution des records du monde et
voilà une des courbes qu'il a pu avoir
c'est l'évolution de tous les records
sportifs pendant plusieurs décennies
vous voyez que ça a évolué très
fortement les petites roues ou la
qu'ouvrier sceller les guerres mondiales
mais ce que vous constatez aussi c'est
que ça commence à plafonner depuis
quelques années on est en train de
plafonner
on n'arrive pas à suivre le rythme on va
pas plus loin trop dense et 7 cette
course aux records sont j'ai quand même
qu'il a fallu 20 ans à renaud lavillénie
pour battre le record du monde de saut à
la perche de bubka de 1 cm 20 ans pour
un centimètre alors intrigués par ces
courbes jean françois toussaint a voulu
voir plus loin il a dans d'autres
domaines il ya une courbe qui est
intéressante que je vous montrais c'est
la courbe de l'espérance de vie
là aussi en france là aussi elle évolue
très fortement elle est due aux progrès
des médical les vaccins l'hygiène etc
et puis depuis quelques années ça semble
plafonner notamment depuis quelques mois
on a vraiment plafonnement
on n'a plus du tout le même rythme de
développement de cette espérance de vie
et là aussi c'est à peu près comme la
courbe des records sportifs
on semble avoir atteint une sorte de
plafond alors à quoi pouvons-nous
attribué cette tendance au plafonnement
et aux limites de cette évolution
c'est qu'on a atteint des constantes
biologiques c'est qu'il ya des
constantes qui sont inscrits dans le
code de la vie et que ces constantes et
existe pour tous les organismes vivants
ici sur cette planète est peut-être
ailleurs si on en trouve d'autres c'est
la même chose c'est isotopique il
yad'énormes que l'on peut pas dépasser
ou alors on pourra le faire mais à
condition de dépenser des ressources
tout à fait considérable
proportionnellement beaucoup plus
importante que ce qu'on a pu faire
aujourd'hui pour gagner quelques
pouillème de vis supplémentaire changer
le curseur biologique de la vie ça va
nous coûter beaucoup plus en ressources
et en moyens alors ce qui est clair
c'est que dans ce mouvement
on va atteindre un point d'inégalités
c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir d'un côté
dans l'humanité des hommes qui vont
pouvoir atteindre peut-être des années
de vie supplémentaires etc et d'autres
qui vont rester sur la voie de garage
peut-être aurons-nous 2 espèce d'humain
un peu comme les pharaons de l'ancienne
egypte avec les immortels et les autres
en tout cas c'est une question qu'il
faut se poser
il est clair que cette évolution va
pouvoir ne sera jamais donné à tout le
monde
il va y avoir certes la possibilité
d'augmenter nos capacités de nous
greffer des prothèses connecter
directement à notre cerveau ça existe
déjà on va pouvoir aussi saint prime et
en 3d des organes de rechange
ça existe on a des gens qui travaillent
là dessus de façon très assidu et très
fortement et on peut imaginer que dans
quelque temps vous aurez une une étagère
avec vous un bout de x 1 voudra un bout
de poumon et c'est de rechange ça peut
toujours servir
on pourra aussi peut-être
transporter notre cerveau ailleurs sur
des machines et alors là mon esprit
deviendra éternelle why not mais ce qui
est clair c'est que il y aura des zones
d'ombré sur la planète ceux qui pourront
atteindre cette immortalité et les
autres ceux qui pourront se payer des
pièces détachées de leurs organes et les
autres ayant nous aurons peut-être deux
catégories d'humains de caste qui sait
mais en tout cas c'est une direction
dans laquelle nous sans nous semblons
nous diriger réellement est ce que cette
inégalité sera tolérée est ce qu'on
pourra admettre que d'un côté il ya ceux
qui peuvent se payer des pouilles m de
vis supplémentaire et les autres
là aussi c'est une question de fond
qu'il faut se poser quand on
s'enthousiasme comme on le fait souvent
sur les biotechnologies les technologies
avancées alors ce qu'il faut retenir de
tout cela c'est pas du tout un propos
technophobes que je suis en train de
vous tenir loin de là je suis pas
atteint de paranoïa id aiguë pas du tout
je pense simplement c'est qu'il faut
comprendre il faut qu'on prenne
conscience que l'information je le
disais au tout début
ces précieux parce que l'information
c'est la vie on ne peut pas laisser tout
faire avec notre information notre
information c'est quoi c'est nos données
c'est nos éléments de vie ce sont nos
cellules nos organes mais c'est aussi
tout ce que vous transmettez partout
dans l'est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les big data les big data c'est le mot
chasse pour ne pas dire big informations
vos informations
moi il ya une question qui me turlupine
depuis longtemps c'est que font les
facebook et autres google avec toutes
nos données toutes nos informations qui
conserve dans des bunkers hyper protégé
ça ne leur coûte et des ressources tout
à fait considérable pour conserver le
moindre de nos emails vous cet email
vous l'avez déjà jetés depuis longtemps
la poubelle eux il le conserve
religieusement
pourquoi pas ok
pour le marketing pour la publicité pour
mieux nous cibler mieux nous vendre des
multitudes de babioles ok mais peut-être
aussi s pour accumuler suffisamment
d'informations pour mieux apprendre
l'humain aux machines
c'est une question aussi qu'il faut se
poser je pense pas qu'on puisse laisser
les scientifiques que j'admire
je ne pense pas qu'on peut les laisser
seuls dans leur labo à ouvrir des boîtes
de pandore quelques fois devant nous on
ne comprend rien ou alors dans notre dos
ce qui est souvent le cas il ya quelques
jours il informations est passé comme ça
très rapidement il y à une équipe de
chercheurs américaine ils ont une
centaine
ils ont ils sont arrivés à créer un
génome artificiel de l'humain recréer le
génome artificiel de l'humain et leur
présentation a été faite à huit clos ils
ont refusé que la presse soit là donc en
fait ce genre d'information est trop
sérieux peut-être pour nous concerner
non ce sont des informations qui
concernent notre vie et il faut qu'on
soit informé et qu'on prenne conscience
de tout cela alors je pense que quand on
comprend que l'information c'est la vie
on doit changer peut-être d'attitude il
y a des un philosophe qui vient de
sortir un bouquin c'est bernard stiegler
qui nous dit quelque chose de simple
mais c'est assez assez bien vu c'est que
la caractéristique principale d'une
innovation disruptive ça y est une
innovation qui va rompre
blaquart est la caractéristique
principale de cette innovation c'est
qu'elle installe un état de fait c'est à
dire qu'elle va tellement vite qu'elle
bouscule le droit la morale l'éthique la
religion et à s'installer dans nos vies
quotidiennes comme ça on la voit presque
pas venir et tout d'un coup elle est là
c'est un état de fait
je pense qu'il ne faut pas laisser des
états de fête s'installe et on va avoir
vous êtes tous en tout cas je l'espère
concernés par ce qui se passe sur notre
planète par le climat vous êtes
sensibilisé je pense aux questions de
biodiversité maintenant depuis quelques
années vous faites attention à ce que
vous mangez
et vous regardez votre alimentation est
ce qu'il y à du bifff hosatte dans votre
pomme que vous avez envie de croquer je
pense qu'il faut avoir la même intention
la même attitude de mise en question de
tout ce qui touche aux technologies et
aux techno science sur le vivant
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
participer au débat il faut peut-être
les susciter on a bientôt des élections
est-ce qu'on va parler de tout ça
pendant les élections c'est des
questions importantes
donc je pense que c'est à nous nous
sommes citoyens du monde
c'est à vous de définir et de jouer le
jeu dans cette multiplication des
technologies qui touche à l'information
culturelle et celle du vivant je répète
l'information c'est sérieux
l'information c'est la vie c'est votre
vie dont il s'agit à vous de jouer
je vous remercie